he consistently ranks in the Forbes list
of the world's wealthiest people he's
one of the best known entrepreneurs of
the personal computer revolution he is
the second most generous philanthropist
in America have been given over twenty
eight billion dollars to charity
he's Bill Gates and here his top ten
rules for success when I started
Microsoft I didn't think of it as all
that risky I mean I was so excited about
what we were doing
it's true I could have gone bankrupt but
you know I had a set of skills that were
highly employable and in fact my parents
were still willing to let me go back to
Harvard and finish my education if I
wanted to you've always got a job with a
bellman and the only the thing that was
scary to me wasn't quitting and starting
the company it was when I started hiring
my friends and they expected to be paid
and and then we had customers who went
bankrupt customers that I counted on to
come through and so then I got this
incredibly conservative approach that I
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll even if
we didn't get in heat any payments
coming in and I'm almost heard of that
the whole time we have about ten billion
now which is pretty much enough for the
next year anyway you know I if you're
gonna start a company it takes so much
energy that you know you it better
overcome your your feeling of risk I
don't think that you necessarily if
you're gonna start a company should do
it at the start of your career I think
there's a lot to be said for working for
a company learning how they do things
you know if you're young it's hard to go
lease premises they made that hard for
me you couldn't rent a car when you were
under 25 at the time so I was always
taking taxis to go see customers the
people would you know people say well
we're gonna go have a discussion in the
bar well I could go to the bar
and you know that's fun because I'll
tell you
when people are first skeptical and
angle this kid doesn't know anything
then when you show them you've really
got a good product and you know
something they actually tend to go
overboard and they think whoa
you know they know a lot let's really do
an incredible amount with these people
so our youth at least in this country
was a huge asset for us once we reached
a certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old older people because they'll
be a little bit conservative about
whether they should come in and take the
risk and it took three or four years
before we could go out into the normal
sort of employment pool but those those
problems that come with starting the
firm you better think of those as as
part of the the pleasure part of the the
challenge that that is part of the the
excitement I want to thank Harvard for
this honor I'll be changing my job next
year and it will be nice to finally have
a college degree on my resume
I applaud the graduates for taking a
much more direct route to your degrees
from our my part I'm just happy that the
Crimson called me Harvard's most
successful dropout I guess that makes me
valedictorian of my own special class I
did the best of everyone who fail
but I also want to be recognized as the
guy who got Steve Ballmer to drop out of
Business School
I'm a bad influence that's why I was
invited to speak at your graduation if
I'd spoken at your orientation fewer of
you might be here today I'm in meetings
a lot my counter gets very full with
those and then at night after the kids
have gone to bed I'm on email a great
deal I get messages during the day
that's my chance to give long responses
and then over the weekend I send a lot
of mail as well as well I take two weeks
a year to just go off and read and think
where I'm not interrupted by work or
anything else I'm just solidly trying to
think about the future and people get to
send me things to read as part of that
so-called think week so it's a nice mix
of things about 25% of the time then I'm
out traveling around meeting with
customers Europe Asia and that sort of
helps me think okay do we have the right
priorities what what are people
responding well to and what would they
they like to see us do better hello I'm
Bill Gates chairman of Microsoft in this
video you're going to see the future
Windows Microsoft first came up with the
Windows concept back in 1983 and today
the leading software users have switched
into the Windows environment it's really
incredible how quickly our powerful
applications like Word and Excel and
PowerPoint have been adopted it's not
just Microsoft applications even
companies like WordPerfect and Lotus
have now come out with Windows
applications and every week we see new
innovative work it's really attracting
all the innovation in the industry we
predicted this a long time ago and now
it's the future the key point there is
you've got to enjoy what you do every
day and for me that's working with very
smart people it's working on new
problems you know every time we think
hey we've had a little bit of
success we're pretty careful not to
dwell on it too much because the bar
gets raised i love bridge bridge helps
you think it's a game you can play your
entire life and keep getting better and
better I think anybody is good at bridge
it's gonna be great a lot of things so I
really encourage people to get involved
and I want to thank the people who put
things together for juniors they'll be
thanking you the rest of their life
because bridge is such great order I
talked to my dad I talked to Warren I
had talked to my wife Melinda so III
have enough people that know me and
actually know where my judgment isn't
its strongest where I might get
overexcited about something or you know
forget to think about something and so
they're good at correcting particular
Melinda good at correcting whatever
those blind spots are and I think it's
good to encourage your friends and
advisers to really give them that
license you know I can go to a party and
forget to say hello to various people or
something that's a very minor example of
my blind spot the hostess a small number
of people that you can turn to on on
certain key things is a great great
asset my best business decisions really
have to do with picking people you know
deciding to go into partnership with
Paul Allen is is probably at the top of
the list and then subsequently hiring a
friend Steve Ballmer and having somebody
who you totally trust who's totally
committed who shares your vision and yet
he has a little bit different set of
skills and also acts as a check on you
you know some of the ideas you come up
with you run by them because you know
they're gonna say hey wait a minute
you know you know have you thought about
this and that and just you know the the
benefit of sparking off of somebody
who's who's got that kind of brilliance
it's not only made it fun but it's
really led to a lot of success so
picking picking a partners is crucial
I had one habit that I developed when I
when I was at college that was actually
very bad habit which was I like to show
people that I didn't do any work and
that I didn't go to classes and I didn't
care and then at the very last minute
like two days before the test I get
serious about it and and people people
thought that was funny
you know that was my positioning the guy
who did nothing until the last minute
then when I went into business that was
a really bad habit and it took me a
couple years to get over that nobody
praised me because I would do things at
the last minute and I tried to reverse
to students I'd actually I didn't think
that highly of who were always organized
and had things done on time I'm I'm
still working on it but procrastination
is not a good good habit bill can change
clothes in the car challenge I'm glad to
give to ALS it's a great cause but I
want to accept this challenge I want to
do it better than it's been done I've
been working on this you know got this
design there we go yeah it's gonna be
great
[Music]
I'm here to join the people bringing
attention to Lou Gehrig's disease by
taking the ALS ice bucket challenge I'm
gonna challenge three more people Elon
Musk Ryan Seacrest and Chris Anderson of
Ted consider yourself challenged you
have 24 hours good luck
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is it true that you can leap over a
chair from a standing position it
depends on the size of the chair I'll
treat a little bit
[Music]
by the way I believe in winners and
losers and especially the freedom to
fail
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because a bunch of you guys
were asking me to so there's this famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'm also curious
to know what you think of Bill Gates as
an entrepreneur and which of the 10
rules most resonates with you leave it
below in the comments and I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon